Democrats are finding it harder and
harder to win the votes of ordinary
American citizens instead they have a
new strategy create a new voter pool at
16 year-olds vote open the borders and
now give the vote even to violent
criminals who are still behind bars in
Iowa and Saturday Bernie Sanders argued
that those who break America's laws
still should be able to help make them
would you commit to that idea would you
commit to that on the nationwide scale I
think that is absolutely the direction
we should go let incarcerated people
vote keep in mind that plenty of prisons
are located in rural areas most of them
are actually it's perfectly possible
that inmates could wind up running the
town that holds them because they'd be
the biggest voting bloc expect that to
be a democratic litmus test by the end
of May author and columnist mark Stein
joins us tonight mark the inmates should
not just be running the asylum but the
town yes the victory beber beber D
Tucker is he's actually the front-runner
because to continue with your Asylum
analogy in the land of the entirely
deranged the fitfully sane man is king
and bernie is the proverbial stop clock
you just 10 minutes ago you mentioned a
burst of sanity on immigration where he
he said we can't have open borders
because all the world's poor will want
to come here he sounded as crazy as
Utica and sounded as evil sometimes I
know I can't I can't tell them apart
Bernie Carlson or Tucker Sanders and
then every so often he just D just
genuflect s' to the insanity of the base
and the party but he's actually much
shrewder than Kamala Harris and Cory
Booker and all the rest of it and and if
he doesn't blow it like he did last time
he he's he's actually going to be as I
said the at least fitfully sane guy the
proverbial stop clock in the day I see a
question that's been bothering me why
couldn't you have
a candidate who was populist in
economics who wasn't you know any kind
of supply-side or libertarian economics
but more conservative on the social
issues you know who was focused on the
country rather than the rest of the
world who was pro-family those are not
incompatible positions are they well I'd
say that's actually where the sweet spot
in politics is you remember like 10-15
years ago we used to have these people
like Christie Whitman and George Pataki
who were so-called fiscally conservative
and socially liberal and I'd say
actually the sweet spot is probably to
be fiscally fiscally liberal and
culturally conservative that's where old
school that's where old school
socialists like Bernie Sanders would
have been quite comfortable being
Barney's brother is alike an old-school
British Labour Party socialist he's all
about the workers by which he means the
British workers not six and a half
billion other workers who want to move
to you once you open the borders section
I think that is actually the sweet spot
I'd be very sympathetic to a candidate I
don't think I'm smart enough to do that
so I got asked about this Alexandria
kasnia cortes started sporting a new
accent while speaking at Al Sharpton's
extremely tax-exempt conference last
week watch the fights been long y'all
this is what organizing looks like look
this is what building power looks like
I'm proud to be a bartender ain't
nothing wrong with that Kazuya Cortez
says she's from the Bronx and she's
always spoken that way she says it was
code switching and that her normal
day-to-day voice is the fake one but
she's not the first Democrat to discover
a long-lost accent was speaking before
an african-american audience you'll
remember watch I don't feel no ways
tired
to far from where I started from
nobody told me that the road would be
easy work if you patronize an audience
that much would you feel shame well look
in fairness I'd say Alexandria is
Hillary's terrible at it absolutely
terrible
I think Alexander if you're going to do
it you have to do it with I'll speak as
a foreigner so I can't tell the
difference between Alexandria calcio
Cortez and William F Buckley Jr all you
Americans sound the same Hilary can't do
it and actually I think that gets to the
heart of it Alexandria could get away
with it in a way that Hillary can't
because I think for Hillary and Joe
Biden when he was saying they don't put
y'all back in chain I think those those
people are saying I want to be something
other than white take my whiteness away
from me I'm Indian like Elizabeth Warren
I'm Hispanic like bata or walk or I'm
just whoever I'm standing in front of at
the moment like Hillary and Alexandria
Cassio Cortez whatever you say about her
is doing it with a much lighter touch no
that's I think it's a fair point I
wonder though were roughly the same age
didn't you grow up in a world where
people are encouraged to be who you
naturally are when you're a kid could
you imagine living in a country where
people are supposed to be ashamed of how
they were born I thought that was the
opposite of what we wanted no no and I
lived through a whole generation of
stupid songs about being authentic
Whitney Houston learning to love
yourself is the greatest love of all
Sammy Davis jr. I got to be me
and all of a sudden we have we have
politicians who are actually trying to
pretend to be so the Elizabeth Warren is
Harvard Law School's first woman of
color and nobody laughs that's the
insanity we laugh at it but everyone who
matters in America takes that nonsense
perfectly seriously I mean is it
sustainable long term to tell people
they should be ashamed of how they were
born no I don't think so I think it's
actually psychologically
unhealthy and I think that's what's
interesting for someone like Alexandria
Ocasio Cortez she's a young woman and
like she's goofing around with that
crowd for Hillary it's it's it actually
says something appalling about our
permanent political class that they can
be in front of us for four decades and
still not know who they are I think it's
really I agree with that it's really
unhealthy I think Mark Steyn great to
see you thank you for that